nevada has reached a settlement with the
advertising company mckinsey and company
for its advertising role in the ongoing
opioid crisis here in nevada
state attorney general aaron ford
explained in a press conference today
that he and his office wanted to hold
mckinsey accountable for its consulting
services
to big pharma companies particularly
they're advising on how to maximize
profits and target doctors to get them
to prescribe
more opioids a.g ford says the impact
opioids have on our state
is huge the devastation caused by the
opioid epidemic is felt by every mother
and father who has lost a child
it's felt by siblings who have lost a
sister or a brother
it's felt by friends and colleagues who
lost one of their own and obviously it's
felt by those still suffering from an
opioid addiction
with those effects in mind a.g ford
chose to pursue
separate legal action against the
company as he felt
our state deserve more than what we
would have received in a multi-state
settlement so from that nevada received
45 million dollars
a.g ford says he's proud that mckenzie
stepped forward to cooperate
and says that holding companies
responsible is the first step
in combating this ongoing crisis